bien alors maintenant on va faire un
anti portrait chinois
français l'auteur si vous étiez un
défaut vous soyez quels défauts je suis
myope
ouais ça c'est à dire c'est formidable
pour tourner murray vous êtes dans la
même pièce que didier schuller et vous
le voyez pas ouais ça peut aider
septième accident de la j'ai eu un
accident naturel peut-être j'ai rêvé
d'être un raz-de-marée est ce que la mer
ont dû chez sun valley tellement de
choses
quelques ex revanche si vous étiez une
perversion de voyeur le voyeurisme
j'aimerais bien rentrer les gens comme
ça qu'on a dans la tête
ouais dans leur tête mais aussi de chez
eux et ça j'adore rsa une mouche si vous
étiez une guerre est la norme en effet
débarquement en normandie
ça c'était il ya eu des français qu'en
débarquant la main des fusilliers marins
qui ont débarqué en normandie
les premiers les premiers sur la plage
de riva-bella et beaucoup sont morts
c'est vrai que c'était très beau sujet
c'est une arme un opinel mon truc comme
ça pour le figa tél ouais écoutons corse
alors un supplice il ya un très beau
supplice
que j'ai en tête qui est celui de
tantale mais les idées dans l'eau et
puis l'eau arrive jusque là il a soif
je propose qu'on remplacement par du
goudron manet ou par un petrus un très
bon bordeaux
c'est une cicatrice je vais pas vous la
montrer mais je suis ouvert delà jusque
là oui c'est la meilleure et j'aime bien
je la ruche à la touche si vous y étiez
une [ __ ]
vous seriez qui moi j'aime pas le mot
parce que j'ai jamais dit ça une femme
et deux mois pourtant en soit chacun son
truc mais j'ai jamais dit ça
à chacun son truc c'est on est tous
comme ça et on en a marre et voilà je
pensais je pensais à simone signoret
dans les diaboliques n'enlève pas la
personne la vérité police nationale joue
madame de merteuil dans l oms
dangereuses d une femme qui fait des
trucs extraordinaires amants diaboliques
mais qui arrive à faire affaire tué son
amant par la maîtresse de 7 à mon sujet
si vous étiez un dictateur quel
dictateur seriez-vous je n'aime pas ça
je pensais vous savez charlie chaplin
quand il joue comme il s'appelle la
dictature et oui avec un ballon que le
monde c'est pas drôle si vous n'êtes
jamais voulu qu'on me pose ces questions
là mais on peut déposer son initiative
est la poser à toi la prochaine si vous
étiez une torture individus tête à tête
avec la reine d'angleterre
ah oui
celle du reiki vous étiez une torture
moi je m'appellerai sodomites ou alors
si j'étais une torture je m'appellerai
cocaïne par exemple voilà ça c'est une
vraie réponse aux médias c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des questions au bois de tout à
l'heure la matraque
voilà un dictateur ou autre mec qui
roule en ferrari
il a envie de jouer la tunisie tient
terroristes ou seriez qui comme
terroriste un mec qui roule en ferrari
qui s'arrêtent pas encore si vous étiez
une injure vous seriez quelle injure va
manger la culotte à ta vieille si vous
étiez une conversion geste par geste est
en forme
ouais vous êtes en forme là si vous
étiez à vis à vis un fils je dirais
comme ils s'appellent l'autre était
michael youn ouais parce que quelque
part sur un vice si le morning live sur
m6 où les matins mais c'est même pas
pour lui faire quoi que ce soit si je
suis pas démago moi c'est vraiment parce
que je le crois il a mal quelque part si
vous étiez une arme ci est énorme
nique ta mère mais avec pas chez sony et
si vous étiez mort
enfin un truc bien horrible la tête dans
une baignoire
barclays on veut que je dise où je veux
mon mag ou ouais d'accord
ridicule brouette je m'attends mourir
pour savoir d'accord ouais mort la tête
aurait bla bla bla et on fermait dessous
ça franchement ça c'est pire que de te
brûler les pieds ou parce que parce que
le gaz ou des choses comme ça on accorde
un moment d'inconscience 6,8 quoi là
c'est vraiment c'est on peut te l'a
serrée et le corps humain trop bien fait
ça d'affaires en monnaies super
conscience
ouais mais quand on te noies ouais c'est
claustrophobie même ceux qui savent pas
ce que c'est après à ce moment france
soir vous étiez de mort d'un mois dans
mon livre je cite une marque est très
belle un moment il raconte la mort de
quelqu'un qu'elle est très belle passe
qui venant de la morphine il et il est
en train de mourir en silence et d'amour
luxueux le temps à temps il demande de
la morphine le type en a pas ou il n'y
en a pas il dit cette phrase
extraordinaire dit tu mets moi sinon
vous êtes un assassin
c'est grâce et la paix c'est ça les
fasse en premier lieu les vielles son
en pension à merci d'être venu je
voulais merci bien